All right,
looks like we're clear.
I can't believe it's
the weekend, and I'm at school!
This is
the best place to hide.
Why? Of all the places
we could hide,
why do I have to sit here
in school?
Mmph!
Where's the last place anyone
would think we would hide?
The scene of our supposed crime,
dummies! We're safe here.
I'd rather be in jail
than in school.
[ Door knob rattling ]
Mm mmph!
Guys? Guys!
Stan!
Guys, thank God!
Just stay right there, Grandpa!
I know all about the deal.
I know what we have to do.
How'd you
find us here?
I figured you guys
were hiding somewhere.
This is the first place
I thought to look.
Mm-hmm!
Yeah, I guess we're dummies,
huh, Kenny?
Yeah, I guess
we're dummies.
Guys, listen --
My stupid grandpa
and a bunch of other old people
made the deal with ManBearPig.
It's here because
of their greediness.
Grandpa:
Everyone's greedy!
Shut up, Grandpa!
I know where to go,
but I need your help.
I'm going to face ManBearPig
and put an end to this deal.
Are you crazy? We just saw
ManBearPig take down Satan.
What the hell are we supposed to
do against it?
We have to try.
[ Siren wails ]
Man: Attention school
shooters...again.
We have you surrounded...again.
Come out
with your hands up!
We just sat in school
for nothing.
Listen!
We know what to do now!
Drop to the ground and put
your hands on your heads.
No, I need
to face ManBearPig.
We have orders!
You're coming with us!
Yates:
Belay those orders!
♪♪
I've been a fool
denying ManBearPig's existence,
and I didn't realize it
till I went home.
My wife...had started
a new life without me.
I wanted to give up,
but instead,
I robbed a bank in Saint Denis,
and I went to an island
north of Cuba.
After I came back, that's
when it all caught up with me.
All the stagecoaches
I had robbed,
all the horses I had stole --
for what?!
We're nothing if we don't
believe in each other!
And God damn it, it's never
too late to start trying
to do the right thing.
You think you know
what that is boys?
Yes, I do.
We're going to face
ManBearPig
and put an end to this deal
once and for all.